[Music]
here's your money briefing for Friday
May 26th I'm J.R Whalen for the Wall
Street Journal
inflation is coming for your summer
vacation but it doesn't necessarily mean
you have to shelve your plans to get
away wsj carry on travel column Miss
Dawn Gilbertson joins us to discuss ways
to preserve your summer getaway so Dawn
let's start with costs how much more
expensive are hotel prices and airfares
this year compared to a year ago they're
up in most cases of course it depends
where you're going and when but just to
give you an example on hotels through
April hotel prices in the top 25 U.S
markets were 180 a night on average and
that was up 10 from last year
and again that's just through April we
all know summer's a much busier period
how about airfares kayak says airfares
are up Summer airfares are up 35 percent
airfares are I mean there are so many
different measures of it it really
depends where you're going and when I
mean if you want to go to Europe right
now and you haven't booked your tickets
you know you could pay as much as two
thousand dollars round trip oh wow
what's driving these prices up well
everybody still wants to go on vacation
it sounds like a broken record at this
point you know the pandemic pent up
travel demand but it's still real I mean
you listen to Airlines you listen to
hotels you listen to theme parks you
listen to anybody associated with travel
and they are still talking Non-Stop
about how many people still want to
travel you think about the past couple
of years you know we went through
lockdowns and even last summer there
were still fears about the pandemic it's
just the first summer in a while where
people just feel the freedom to go
wherever they want I think it's the
first summer where a bigger pool of
Travelers feel that right you know last
summer was Bonkers anybody who had an
airport last summer knows you know that
it was super crowded it's been super
crowded all year and you can even go
back to the summer of 2021 and see a lot
of strength what it is now is that by
and large most of the coveted travel
restrictions are gone in most places you
know so people that maybe say last
summer and Europe was strong last summer
but what the experts say about Europe
this summer is that anybody who maybe
was on the fence last year and worried
okay well the restrictions are going
away but what if they don't now they're
just planning with abandon to go are
there still deals to be had out there
for hotels and flights are there online
tools people could use to plan a
vacation but not drain their bank
account the key is is to be flexible
right I mean I know like families with
kids in school and even in college they
can't be super flexible but you
certainly can be flexible with your day
of week travel you certainly can be
flexible
um with how long you're going on your
trip so I mean and your destination
frankly right you know I talked to
somebody who really wanted to go to
Europe was put off by the high airfare
prices and he's now going to Scotland
and the only reason he's going to
Scotland is because it was the lowest
airfare to Europe from where he lives
yeah you spoke to people who were facing
these higher prices but they're
undeterred from going away this summer
you know from a number standpoint how
are they making this work they're just
adjusting their expectations right and
not everybody's you know flying budget
for sure what they're doing is I talked
to a family who likes to do a summer
vacation kind of a reunion a small group
of six every other year and so a couple
years ago they went to Hawaii and made
it work this year and we're not talking
some big luxurious long trip this was a
three-night trip they were in four days
they were hoping to go to the Dominican
Republic It's a family of six and
airfare alone was eight hundred dollars
per person from Atlanta so they just
were like yeah this is you know they're
like this is not worth it this this trip
is going to be six thousand dollars you
know that money could be better spent so
they are now going to Hilton Head in a
minivan all right a minivan is one way
to do it sounds like this might be the
summer of flexibility in trade-offs it
definitely is plenty of people are
looking for ways to
ritual but stay on a budget but then
let's be realistic here plenty of people
are still planning very extravagant
trips to Europe I interviewed a
grandfather from the Boston area who
since 2020 has been trying to take his
grandsons and his daughter and
son-in-law to Ireland where he's from
and they're flying business class to
Dublin they're doing Adventures by
Disney tour they're doing private cars
and nothing would have kept them home
this year from Europe but if you're
really struggling with these airfares
this sounds like an opportunity for
folks to explore those budget Airlines
you wrote about earlier this year you
know it's certainly the time maybe to
broaden your search of Airlines to
include some Airlines maybe you wouldn't
have before but my caveat on this front
is always always always make sure that
if you're going to an event that you
have to be there at a certain time build
in some buffer time some of the budget
Airlines just don't have they don't have
daily flights or they don't have
multiple flights a day so if they cancel
your flight you know do you want to miss
that wedding right yeah that makes a lot
of sense and it's great if you can get a
decent airfare but summer tends to be a
rough season for the airlines budget
Airlines or the Legacy Airlines last
year it seemed like almost daily we
heard about widespread delays how are
the airlines preparing for this summer
well they can't stop talking enough
about how many more people they hired
we're talking in the tens of thousands
they're just talking about how they are
prepared they learned a very very costly
lesson last year does that mean things
are going to go super smooth this summer
I mean they sure hope so but I certainly
wouldn't put my money on that because
obviously weather is a huge factor in
flight delays and cancellations that's
Wall Street Journal travel columnist Don
Gilbertson and before we go a quick
programming note we'll be off on Monday
for Memorial Day but we'll be back in
your feed on Tuesday and that's it for
your money briefing this week our
supervising producer is Melanie Roy and
our executive producer is Chris zinsley
I'm your host J.R Whalen thanks for
listening and have a great weekend
[Music]
thank you